hey guys welcome to a new series that
I'm super excited to get started it's
the introduction to game development in
this series we're going to cover a lot
of basic topics like collision detection
the game loop handling different frames
per second all kinds of cool issues that
we're gonna get into it's all gonna be
in this vanilla JavaScript no
third-party libraries of framework all
we're going to use is the html5 canvas
and we're gonna be drawing it directly
on the browser so if you know just a
little bit of JavaScript you should be
able to follow it just fine
have fun and enjoy series
so we're going to be using code sandbox
that I owe for this project this would
be a good way to use multiple JavaScript
files in one project let's go ahead and
get started here I will say create
sandbox I'm just going to do a vanilla
app here alright let's get rid of this
div here let me update my preferences
here let's go to editor let's make line
height larger let's make the font size
larger all right should be good so we
have a empty app here we have our
index.js file let me go ahead and delete
everything in there and we have our
project setup first thing we want to do
is create our html5 canvas let's give it
an ID
I call it game screen the canvas is
going to be what we draw our game in
that's uh let's create some styling here
I'm just gonna throw it up here real
quick because all we need is we need to
say game screen let's give it a border
of one pick solid black and let's give
the canvas itself a width and a height
so let's do width of 800 pixels and a
height of 600 pixels there you go now
you can see we have our game screen here
and this is what we will draw our game
in
so we now have our canvas here let's get
rid of this guy let's learn how to draw
something on the canvas let's go into
our index.js file let's let's first grab
the canvas so let's do let canvas equals
document dot get element by ID and we're
looking for the game screen and we need
the context of the canvas so next we'll
say let context equal canvas get context
and we're going to be using
two-dimensional context here the context
gives us a rendering context for
actually drawing to the canvas I'm gonna
rename this to CTX just because we're
gonna be using it a lot in this project
and context is kind of a long word just
keep typing over and over again now I'll
simply just draw a square onto our
canvas so they say CTX dot fill rect so
we're going to fill a rectangle we're
gonna start it at coordinates of 2020 so
20 on the x-axis 20 on the Y and how big
do we want it we want to say the width
will be 100 and the height will be 100
there we go simple square if we want to
change the color we can tell the context
let's fill the style equal to this value
let's make it red so f00 now we have a
red square now do note that once you set
the fill style every time you make a new
drawing it's gonna use that same fill
style so if we do CTX dot fill rect
let's do another one
at 200 200 and make it a little bit
smaller 50 by 50 that square is also
going to be red if you want it to be
blue we have to update the fill style to
0 0 F and now that one is going to be
blue so the fill style sets the fill
style and then you're gonna fill a
rectangle with that style that you've
recently specified
next let's talk about clearing the
screen if you notice here we're drawing
these two squares on here if I update
this let's let's move it to 220 you see
that it turned into like a rectangle it
kind of stretched live to 40 same thing
now it's not actually stretching what's
happening is every time you redraw onto
the canvas what was previously on the
canvas is still there so when you're
working with a game where objects are
moving around on the screen you want to
make sure you clear what was previously
there before so all we want to do is
we're just gonna say T C T X thought
clear right so it's gonna clear
everything on the screen but you have to
give it an area that you want it clear
so we're gonna start at 0 0 and we're
gonna do the whole screen which was 800
wide by 600 tall so now if something
gets updated 350 360 this is actually
going to move on on the screen you're
not gonna have what was previously there
so this is going to be a very important
part of our game to make sure we clear
it between every frame
now we know how to draw to the screen
let's first start working on our paddle
the paddle will be at the bottom and
you'll be able to move it left and right
in order to catch the ball and bounce it
back up towards the bricks so let's go
ahead and get rid of these squares we're
drawing here and let's create a class to
handle all the aspects of a paddle let's
go into source create a new file I'm
just gonna call it paddle j/s and we'll
have a class of paddle you might need a
constructor and we're going to need a
method for drawing the paddle now the
draw method is gonna need the context so
we'll pass that in and we're gonna need
some attributes for this paddle so let's
set some things up here when this paddle
is created let's set a width I'm just
gonna guess here what we can always
update this later I'm gonna say 150
let's set the height equal to I don't
know maybe 30 pixels and we need to
position so they should probably know
how big the game screen is so that way
if we update the game screen later we
can just set it in one place so in our
index let's have a constant here of game
with 800 and a constant of game height
600 and we will pass this in-game hiked
there we go we'll pass this into our
paddle class when we want to create it
so our paddle is going to take a game
width and a game height
so the position of the paddle needs to
be in the center of the screen so let's
see here I'll say this top position
equals and I like to make the position
an object that way we can say position X
is you know this position position Y is
this position and then we can just
update this by saying something like
this stop position X and you can update
it so let's go with this right now
why we're gonna be at the very bottom of
the screen but a little bit above it so
we want to say game height - this dot
height - how much do we want off the
bottom let's just say 10 pixels I'll
explain this in a little more detail
once we finish it we want to start in
the middle of screen so we'll say game
width / 2 - this dot width / - now let's
just draw this up and then I can better
explain how this is working
so we'll say CTX dot fill rect we want
to say it's gonna be in this top
position got X this top position dot Y
and the size of it is this thought width
and this dot height so now we have our
draw function let's go back into index J
s we're gonna say we're gonna have a
paddle here it's going to be a new
paddle and it takes in the game width
and game height so game with game height
and we just need to say paddle dot draw
now it's giving us an error because it
doesn't know what paddle is so on our
paddle class we need to export this
export default class paddle so now we're
exporting this so in our index.js file
we can import paddle from source paddle
alright so now that this class knows
what or this file knows what paddle is
we're instantiating it and then we're
gonna save draw the draw needs to have
the context of our game there we go so
we have our paddle drawn now let me go
back and explain how we calculated this
so we want this to be in the middle of
the screen let's think about the the y
position first the squares drawn from
the top-left corner so if we want this
to be at the bottom of screen but off
the page by about 10 pixels what we need
to do is when you take the game height
so 800 which will be right down here at
the bottom move it up the height of the
square which is 30 and then subtract 10
to give it just that little bit of
buffer so game height minus this height
minus 10 puts it right here off the
bottom of the page for the x position we
want to Center it between 0 and 600 so
in order to do that we take the game
width and divide it by 2 that puts us at
300 which would be right in the center
but since the square is built from the
top-left corner
we need to move it to the left by half
of the width and that gives us our
center position here working with
classes like this allow us to know that
this file is the paddle we can adjust
the height maybe do it by 20 that looks
a little better and we also want to set
the knee style remember the the context
was set by that last time we did the
fill style so let's do CTX dot fill
style equals
I don't know let's just do let's just do
a green how about a light blue all right
that works
now your next step is probably going to
want to be moving the paddle or moving
things on the screen but in order to do
that we need to establish a game loop a
game loop is something that runs every
frame updates all the objects redraws
them in the new position and and then
moves on to the next frame so let's see
what that would look like now you would
think you could just do a you know a
simple while loop and and iterate over
everything redraw the paddle but in
reality that's not going to work well
because you have to think about all the
computers running at different speeds a
very powerful computer is going to run
this while loop a lot faster than a much
slower computer so what we're gonna do
is we're going to create a new function
I'll call it game loop and inside of
here we're going to want to clear our
canvas we're going to want to update our
paddle which let's just put that in here
real quick so update the update function
let's just for for now let's just say
this position dot X plus equal 5 now we
want to change it 5 pixels per per
second so the update function needs to
bring in a delta time or you might see
it as DT and a lot of other games what
is called Delta time that means the
change in time how much time has changed
since the last time this has been
updated so we're going to update this
we're gonna say 5 divided by the Delta
time so it means it's gonna go 5 pixels
divided by how much time is in past so
let's go get that Delta time inside our
index.js function we need to know what
the last time was so we're going to
start at 0 now this loop needs to bring
in a timestamp
and we need to do pedaled drawl fasten
the CTX and we need to calculate how
much time has passed so we will do here
but delp's of time Delta time equal
timestamp - last time so how much time
has passed and now we need to set the
last time equal to the current timestamp
so where does the timestamp come Pam
come from we're going to request an
animation frame from the browser and
give it the game loop so every time this
runs it'll say hey when the next frame
is ready call this game loop again and
pass it the timestamp and we'll
calculate the Delta time pass it into
our paddle to update function and
continue so just to get this thing to
start let's just call game loop once
another reason this isn't working is
because on our very first frame we're
not passing a timestamp at all which is
fine because we're starting at zero but
the paddle is expecting to divide by the
delta time error which is going to be
zero so we can just put in here if not
dealt the time returned so if no delta
time is passed in we'll just return and
now you can see that our paddle is
moving across the screen all right so
let's just remove this and we'll handle
actually moving the paddle with inputs
and another episode in the future so
just as a quick recap we have our game
loop that runs every frame it calculates
how much time has passed it clears the
screen it updates the paddle and then it
redraws the paddle and then again it
calls the game loop again with the next
frames timestamp
now let's create a simple input handler
to listen to a couple key events for
moving the arrows left and right these
will be used to move the paddle left and
right on the screen let's create a new
file call it input J s and then here
we'll have a new class of input handler
and let's give it a constructor and
let's export this so now in our index J
s file we can simply import it there we
go alright so what should this thing do
let's just add an event listener for
listening to a keydown event on the
arrow keys document dot event listener
we're gonna listen to queue down and
we're going to give it a function that
passes the event and let's just alert
the event key code in our index.js file
all we need to do is instantiate it
before the game loop so new input
handler so I push the left arrow key we
get 37 if I push the right arrow key I
get 39 that's great so now we just need
to make a little switch here
event.keycode so we're gonna do
different things based on the key code
so if we have 37 this is going to move
left and if we have 39 we're going to
move right
we can get rid of this alert all right
let's check it out
so left arrow key move left right arrow
key move right next we need to tell the
paddle how to handle these movements
next let's actually move the paddle with
a key down here so let's remove this
alert and we're going to say we want to
we want to call the paddle and we want
to say moved left we don't know what the
paddle is so let's let's put it in our
constructor and in our index.js file
let's pass the paddle to our input
handler all right now we need to create
the move left function on our paddle so
let's say here and move left and what's
gonna happen here let's say we have the
paddle has a max speed let's set it to
10 and the current speed that it is
moving is zero all right so when we move
left we want this speed to be equal to
negative max speed so it'll be moving at
negative ten pixels per second in our
update function we now want to say this
stop position dot X plus this speed so
when we tell it to move left the speed
becomes negative ten and then when we
update the x position gets moved a minus
ten amount let's try it out there we go
so the paddle is moving I want to slow
it down a little bit here maybe move it
to seven and the other issue is once it
gets to the edge of the screen it keeps
going we want to make sure that it
cannot leave the bounds of our game so
what we'll say here is we'll say if this
stop position dot X is less than zero
this stop position dot X will be set to
zero
there we go now it stops when I hit the
edge of the screen now all we have to do
is do our move right and we'll be done
so right here will say pedal dot move
right go into our paddle class make a
move right function just speed equals
this dot max speed so sets it to the
positive seven we have here whoops let's
refresh that so there we go we can move
it left we can move it right but again
just like with the left bounds we need
to make sure that it can't go off the
right side of the screen so if this stop
position dot X plus this dot width is
greater than the game width which do we
have here we do not have so let's let's
save this here just that game wit goes
game width and this die game well we
don't need the height here so let's just
stick with the game width if the
position plus if the x position plus the
width of the paddle is greater than the
game width then this stop position dot X
is equal to this game width minus this
dot width now does that make sense
let's move it to the right so if the
exposition plus the width of the paddle
is past the edge of the game screen we
set the exposition right here where the
exposition plus the width will line up
perfectly with our game screen
alright now let's work on stopping the
paddle when the player releases a key so
let's just copy this real quick but
instead of key down we're gonna do key
up and let's just change this to stop so
if we release one of these keys we're
gonna stop the paddle let's just create
a quick function in here stop this speed
equals zero now let's try it out alright
that works great but here's the problem
if I'm pushing left and then I push
right and I live release the left key it
kind of stops for a second so what we
need to do is we need to make sure that
it's moving in the same direction that
we're releasing so if we release the
left key we need to say if paddle speed
is less than 0 if it is traveling left
we will stop if we release the right key
we need to check if the paddle speed is
greater than zero so if it is traveling
right and we release the right key it'll
then stop let's try it there we go no
stuttering now it works as intended
alright next let's learn how we can draw
an image onto our canvas first we need
an image so let's go and create a new
directory called assets and maybe in
there we'll create a new folder called
images and in here let's go ahead and
upload a file see I have a bald PNG file
Here I am a terrible pixel art so please
forgive me alright so we have our bowl
now we need to load the image into HTML
so let's go in here and let's just say
image source equals assets images vol
dot PNG all right so we have our ball
showing up on our page but we want to in
our canvas so let's give it an ID of
image ball and let's also just hide it
from the web page so all images will be
display:none all right so now that we
have it here even though you can't see
it we can grab it using this ID so let's
go into our index j s file let's see
here let's just put a spot here images
will say lit ball I'll say image ball
equals document dot get element by ID
and we'll pass it the ID we gave it here
so we have the image now whenever we
want to draw it we can just say CTX draw
image image bowl and the position and
there you go now maybe this size doesn't
work for us maybe we want to bump it up
to maybe 16 by 16 so let's specify that
here so we have the image the position x
position Y and the width and height of
our ball now let's just simply refactor
this into its own class so let's create
a new file here ball a s and here we
will explore a default class of ball
we're going to need a constructor and
we're also going to need a draw function
and later we will also do an update
function that is to do later all right
so the constructor when you do get the
image so we'll say this dot image equals
and then we can grab this document get
element by ID pop that in there we can
get rid of this and we can also grab
this draw image and move it into our
draw function we need to pass it the
context and this will be this dot image
so when we create the ball class it'll
grab the image from the page and every
time we want to draw it will draw it
here well
so inside index we will import ball from
source ball and let's say that ball
equal new ball
then in our game loop we need to draw
the ball and there it is and now we have
a new clean class that we can use to
change the position of the ball as it
moves around in our game world
before we start moving the ball around
on the screen let's just clean up a
couple issues real quick in our index.js
file we have a couple hard-coded values
down here should be the game width and
this should be the game height also
instead of just calling the game loop
like this we can use the
requestanimationframe
and that will give us a valid time stamp
which means we can go to our paddle JS
file and in our update function we can
get rid of this check here let's make
sure everything still works all right
let's move on to moving the ball let's
go to our ball class our update function
is going to take a delta time so we can
know how far to move let's set the speed
and let's just hard code it for now and
we'll adjust it based on which direction
it's moving later let's give it an X
speed and a Y speed
all right now on the update function we
can just say let's see here we also need
a position so let's do this top position
let's give it an X of 10 and a Y of 10
now in our update function we can say
this dot position dot X plus equals this
dot speed X and this dot position dot y
plus equals the stuff speed del Y and in
our draw function we need to update it
so that it is drawn at this stop
position X and this dot position dot y
let's go back to index let's make sure
we're we're not updating it so let's say
bald update pass in the Delta time and
there we go we have our ball moving all
right now let's clean up these extra
hard-coded values right here so let's
give the ball a size set up to 16 and
we'll set both of these to this dot size
whoops
there we go so we're gonna draw the
image with its position and its size now
if there's any power-ups that might
change the size of the ball we can
simply just change the value and it will
draw it at a different size now we need
to worry about bouncing off the walls
just like the paddle we'll need to take
in the game width and the game height so
we know where the walls are at so back
in our index J s file when we
instantiate the ball we're going to give
it game width and game height all right
so now the ball knows how big the game
world is let's talk about the collisions
here in our update function we need to
say if this stop position X so it's
already been moved if it's greater than
this that game width or if this stop
position X is less than zero we need to
reverse the speed on the x axis
all right now when you do the same thing
for y if the position Y is greater than
a game height which later will change
this to either B the game over or you
lose your try and if the position Y is
less than 0 the speed Y gets reversed
when you change this to speed X alright
let's see if it bounces off the bottom
wall here there we go
I can't quite see the edge of the canvas
all right we need to adjust this just a
little bit on the Y we need to say if
this position Y Plus this dot size is
greater than the height there we go same
thing on the right if the position X
plus this dot size let's let's bump up
the speed a bit all right looking good
let's do a little bit of refactoring
right now we're passing two parameters
to both the bowl and the paddle we're
passing the game width and the game
height if we're gonna pass more
parameters like the ball might need to
know where the paddle is we're starting
to just chain on more and more
parameters to these constructors that is
a sign that things need to be refactored
and cleaned up a bit so let's take care
of that let's go ahead and create a new
file we'll call it game J s export
default class game alright so this guy
is going to be in charge of managing all
this for us let's go to index J s let's
get rid of the ball paddle and input
Handler and let's move it out to this
new class so let's give it a constructor
we're gonna need to pass it the game
width and the game height so right here
will say this duck game width equals
game width and this duck game height
equals game height all right now instead
of passing the ball and the paddle the
game width and game height will just
pass it an instance of this
let's move this out into a new function
the car call it the start function so
we're ready for our game to start we
will instantiate these objects
we'll have our ball we'll have our
paddle and we'll have our input handler
now let's go ahead and import these guys
so our paddle and play Handler and ball
now let's refactor our paddle and ball
class instead of taking game width and
game height we're just going to take the
game object our game width will be our
game game with a game-high twig in game
height same thing for our paddle we'll
just take in a game object game dot game
width game game height and this needs to
know the game that game with as well
alright now let's create our game object
game equal new game past the game width
pass the game height game to start
that'll instantiate it and we need to
import it
alright next we have this game loop
trying to update and draw our objects so
let's let's take this out and what if we
just said gamed update and game dot draw
those functions don't exist yet so let's
let's take care of that so we'll do an
update and a draw function now what we
have before is we had paddle update
paddle draw so let's just move these
around
it's update we're going to update this
paddle and then we're going to draw the
paddle and this function same thing with
our ball let's update the ball and let's
draw the ball
next we need to know the Delta time so
let's just pass it in and let's pass in
our context
let's go back to index J s and we'll
pass in the Delta time and the context
now let's take a look at our errors here
ah the paddle and ball don't exist on
the object so let's just change this to
this
there we go all right back to where we
started now as we make more and more
objects such as all the bricks we don't
want to have to say this brick dot
update we're just writing the same thing
over and over again so let's let's clean
this up a little bit let's do this dot
game objects this is going to be an
array we could just say here this ball
pit stop paddle and then in here instead
of doing each of these we can just say
this game objects for each object object
update Delta time o because we need to
remove these guys
same thing with draw this game optics
for each object object draw CTX so now
any object we make all needs to do is
have an update and a draw method and we
can just add it here so if we add 40
bricks we just add the 40 bricks to this
array and the rest of this game class
takes care of it automatically for us so
a quick review our end XJS file just
starts a new game by instantiating a
game object telling it to start and then
in our game loop we clear our screen and
then we tell the game to update and draw
and our game class now passes its own
instance to the object so that they can
get any information they need so the
ball can get information as to where the
paddle is located on the screen then we
just put all the game objects into an
array and we have an update and a draw
function that handle updating and
drawing all of our game objects in our
world
now that we have our refactoring out of
the way and we have everything wrapped
up into a game class let's handle the
collision between the ball and the
paddle inside of our ball class we're
given the game let's just make sure we
have it here available for the ball to
use now we can use the game within any
of our other functions just to prove a
point inside of our update function
let's do a console log this dot game dot
paddle dot position dot X so now every
update we're gonna log where the paddle
is even though we're currently looking
at the ball object as I move the paddle
left and right you can see the position
is being printed out at the current
value our update function currently
updates the position of the ball and
checks to see if it is hitting a wall
on the left or right of the screen
and we also check to see if it hits a
wall on the top or bottom so now let's
check with the paddle
now the ball is always going to collide
with the paddle with the bottom of the
ball hitting the top of the paddle so
let's say bottom of ball equals this dot
position
dot y plus this dot believe it sighs yes
this size and let's do the top of paddle
equals this dot game dot paddle dot
position dot y now that we have this
information we can start with our
collision check if the bottom of the
ball is greater than or equal to the top
of the paddle so we're hitting the
paddle we want to reverse the speed we
also want to set the ball so it's just
touching the paddle so the position Y is
equal to this game paddle position Y
minus the size so now if we take a look
when the ball comes down and it hits the
paddle it'll bounce right off of it all
right now here's an issue all we're
doing right now is checking where it's
at on the y axis so if it's left of the
paddle it still bounces off so we need
to know if the ball is actually hitting
within the bounds of the paddle let's do
left side of paddle is this game that
paddle dot position X and let's do right
side of paddle equals this game paddle
position X plus this game paddle width
so now we know where the left and right
sides of the paddles are let's extend
our if statement here so if the bottle
the ball is greater than the top of the
pedal and this position dot X is greater
than or equal to the left side of the
paddle and if this dot position dot X
plus the size is less than equal to the
right side of the panel get rid of that
let's try it out I'll see if we can
still bounce the ball off the paddle we
can now let's see if it goes to the left
side of the paddle all right it does
pass through and hit the the ground
which will in the game now let's check
the right side of the paddle just to
make sure that is working as well all
right so we now have a basic collision
between the ball and the paddle working
and we can bounce the ball back towards
the bricks that we will build soon
alright let's introduce some bricks to
the game as you can see I've already
loaded a brick PNG file here into our
images folder let's load that into our
index.html now let's create a new class
class we need a constructor it will need
an update function and a draw function
alright let's just copy some code from
our ball class here
pass on the game going to get image
brick you'll need this we will set the
position in the constructor will not
have a speed because it's not moving and
instead of size will have a width just
say 52 and a height of 24 and our draw
function will need to take the context
we will draw the image the position and
the width and the height all right now
let's start adding these bricks to the
game
in our game class alright let's first
import the brick
now let's create a new brick for an
example give it a position and let's add
it to our game objects all right so we
now have a brick loaded into our game
let's just see how easy it is to make
lots of bricks our brick width was 52 so
let's do this
the bricks equal a new array let's do a
loop of ten times and for each one we
will push a new brick object position of
X will be I times 52 and the Y position
will be let's say 30 now to add an array
to an existing array we can just use a
spread operator
all right so that's all it's needed to
have a bunch of bricks displayed into
our game world
now this is not a whole lot of fun and
building a loop and manually pushing
these bricks we want to have different
levels with different arrangement of
bricks so let's go ahead and take care
of that now let's create a new file and
let's define what a level looks like
it's a level one it's going to be an
array number of arrays so let's just
write it out and then I'll explain what
we're doing here
so decided I want to do 10 bricks per
row
so as you can see here we have four
arrays within the level array each one
corresponding to a row with ones and
zeros so what I'm gonna do here is
anytime there is a one that'll become a
brick a zero is just going to be an
empty space so for this first level
we'll have you know three rows of full
bricks and then the top row will just
have some bricks here and there now we
need a function to actually turn these
levels into the bricks so we'll need to
know about a brick and we'll also need a
function that will build it now this
function needs to know what level you're
using so you'll pass at the level and
they will create a bunch of bricks
all right so let's start working on this
so let's loop through our level to get
each row and then for each row we'll
will get a brick and now we will create
our brick so let's take a look at our
brick constructor brick takes the game
and the position so we'll need to also
pass that in the game here
all right so if the brick equals one so
if it is set to be added to the game we
will say bricks push new brick passes
the game and the position we need to
create the position just leave that as a
placeholder for now
so our X&Y what are we going to do here
so our full game width is 800 we're
doing 8 bricks per row so let's change
our brick size to 80 so 80 times 10 is
800 we have the height of 24 so if we go
back to our levels x will be 80 times a
brick and X the Y let's start it at 20
from the top plus 24 times the row index
all right let's check it out see if it
works let's go into our game let's get
rid of this let's import our level so we
have build level and level one that
we're going to import from levels
now our bricks we're going to say build
level I'm going to pass it the game and
level one and we need to remember that
we should return the bricks back to the
game they're our first level has been
built and now we have a simple place
that we can go in here and we can modify
our level so we could change it a little
bit just change this top row son and now
you have a completely different look
let's move the bricks a little further
away from the top of the game so let's
go into our create levels let's bump
this up to 50 maybe 75 there we go now
we have room once you break through to
have it bounce up against the ceiling
there and we have our level creator
complete
so we now need to detect the collision
between the ball and each brick of the
game now right now our ball class has
some collision detection between the
ball itself and a paddle which is a
rectangle just like a brick so I'd like
to reuse this code but it's best not to
copy and paste it let's put it someplace
reusable let's copy this let's create a
new file I'll call it collision
detection now it's just export a
function and we'll need the ball and a
game object let's go ahead and paste our
code in here so we have the bottom of
the ball we're also going to need the
top of the ball we have the top of the
game object we have the left side of the
game object and we have the right side
of the object
we also need the bottom of the object
all right now instead of this we need to
refer to the ball and instead of the
game paddle we need to refer to the game
object itself
all right now let's update our if
statement if the bottom of the ball is
greater than or equal to the top of
object and the top of the ball is less
than or equal to the bottom of object
and the ball position X is greater than
or equal to the left side of object and
the ball position X plus the ball size
is less than or equal to the right side
of the object then we're going to do
whatever we need to do so instead of
this we're just going to return true
otherwise we'll turn false this function
is only telling us if there's a
collision and not what to do with it now
let's go back into our ball file let's
import this function at the top called
the function and detect collision
now down here at our where we're doing
our collision detection will remove all
of this and instead say if detect
collision I'm going to pass it the ball
which is this and the paddle game dot
paddle let's make sure that still works
alright does so that's a successful
refactor now it'll be easy for us to
detect collision with the bricks let's
go into the brick class go into our
update function here first we need to
import our function and we will just say
if detect collision between the ball and
the object which is the brick itself
let's tell the ball to reverse the Y
speed
let's check that out as you can see it's
bouncing off the bricks here at the top
of our screen now we need to just remove
the brick from the game once it's been
hit so I'm going to add a property here
called marked for deletion once it's
been hit we will mark it true now our
game is going to be responsible for
removing these bricks from the game so
we in our games update function we're
going to update all the objects then
we're going to filter it down to the
ones that are not marked to for deletion
and there we go we have successfully
made it so that the ball can bounce off
the bricks and destroy them
work with pausing the game first let's
update the ball so it doesn't start
above the bricks but down here so that
it's not trapped let's go into our ball
file let's set the Y position to 400 and
let's set the speed to a negative two
there we go all right now let's go into
our input handler we're going to need a
new input here
kikyo 27 is the escape key that's what
we're gonna use to pause the game so
we'll do here as we'll say game dot
pause or let's say toggle pause because
they could unpause the game as well so
this class doesn't know what the game is
so let's pass it into the constructor
all right now let's go into our game
class this is where we'll do the
remaining of the work all right so our
input handler we need to pass in the
game which is this and we need a new
function called toggle pause so we're
gonna introduce here is game States a
game state is going to tell the game
where it's at is it paused is it running
is it at the title screen the game over
screen we're gonna be working with this
for a few episodes let's go ahead and
create here a constant and we're going
to define all of our states so we'll
have paused give that a value of 0
running 4 when the game is running the
menu and also game over all right so
we're all gonna work with pause and
running for today when we start a game
we want to set the game state equal to
game state running later we'll start the
game at the menu but for now we're going
to keep it the way it's running right
now
next we need to toggle pause so if this
game state is paused we're going to set
the game state to running so if it's
paused and they click the pause button
it'll unpause the game otherwise we're
going to pause the game now right now
it's not doing anything because we're
not selling the game to stop running
when we hit the pause button so inside
of update function let's just say if
this game state is pause we're not gonna
update anything so right there I just
hit the Escape key and the game is
frozen hit it again and it starts
running again alright now let's do a
little display to show that the game is
actually paused and not frozen it's
inside of our draw function we still
want to draw everything even though the
game is paused
let's first shade the whole screen so
it's a little darker so let's see here
we have our context let's create a
rectangle that covers the whole screen
let's fill it
let's do an RGBA so we can do black but
with 50% opacity so you can see through
it and let's fill it so there we go
but we only want this to show when we're
paused so let's just do if this game
state is paused and now if I pause the
game it shades it gray unpause it and
goes back to white let's add a little
bit of text as well let's create a font
of 30 pixels Arial let's fill it fill it
white looks a line at center and let's
let's let's fill it and position it so
we say fill text pause and we're going
to put it 50% on the x-axis and y-axis
so the X will be our game width over 2
and the y will be our game height over 2
let's pause the game and unpause it
alright now we can pause and pause the
game
so the next thing we need to do is add a
menu screen here so that if the game
will not just start right away but the
user will be able to hit the spacebar
and start the game so we already have
our game state menu set up here so let's
start the game when we start the game
we'll start it at a menu next we need to
go down to our update we don't want to
update anything if it is paused or if
this game state is at the menu let's
change these to triple equals there we
go next in our draw function we have our
pause state drawing here let's make a
new one for the menu
let's update these comparators let's
make it a solid black and in our text
instead of pause we will say press
spacebar to start there we go
now we need the input handler to trigger
the start of the game let's go into our
files let's go into input case 32 I
believe is a spacebar game that start
now we're going to need to modify our
game a little bit so when we start this
is when the game is actually going to
start when the game is created we need
to set up some things so we'll move this
stuff up to our constructor the bricks
will be built when the first level is
loaded the game objects will be loaded
when the game is started input handler
needs to be moved up here
let's clean this up a little bit alright
so that should be everything we need to
start the game let's go ahead and try it
mmm nothing happens oh yes the last
thing we need to do here is when we
start the games we need to change the
game state to running let's refresh
all right now what is also calling this
dart here let's go look at our index.js
file oh yes we're immediately calling
the game start when we load the page
let's remove that now we have an air on
our draw function issue is that the game
objects has not been initialized yet so
let's do that here set it equal to an
empty array alright we now have our menu
screen if I hit space the game will
start and everything works we expect it
I hit space again though you'll notice
that it actually rebuilds the level so
let's fix that real quick if this game
state is not equal to the menu then we
will return so only the menu can trigger
the start of the game let's try this
again there we go it doesn't rebuild the
level automatically
let's now handle the GAMEOVER state all
right so the game should have a number
of lives or balls or or tries I'm gonna
call it lives I'm gonna just set it to
one for now so we can test this now
let's go down to our update function if
this dot lives equals zero
this game state will be equal to game
over so we run out of lives we in the
game and we don't want to update
anything else if is game over so there
we go once we hit game over the update
will stop running now we just need to
draw our game over screen let's just
copy this here from our menu and we will
say game over just need to add an extra
brace there there we go so we have our
game over screen built let's just test
it real quick to see what it looks like
there we go
so you to fix some brackets let's format
the document this is what it'll look
like now we need to actually get the
game to go to the game over state once
the game is lost so let's change this
back to menu now inside of our ball
class we're checking collisions with
both the top and the bottom we just want
to check a wall on top so if the
position of the ball is plus the size is
greater than the game height that's the
bottom of the game so let's cut this out
if we hit the bottom of the game do we
have access to the game here we do this
game dot lives - - all right let's try
it out I'm going to start the game
I'm going to purposely let it hit the
bottom here game over perfect
now what's going to happen when the ball
gets below the game now we're going to
lose a life but it's immediately going
to game over even though we have three
lives set here that's because the ball
is never being reset let's grab this
here I want to pull this out and I'm
going to create a function called reset
so that'll reset our position and speed
so down here whoops
when we lose a life we will call reset
let's try it out
so it should go below the screen it'll
reset so now we're down to two lives and
a reset we have one life remaining game
over
now the last thing we're going to do in
this series is allowing the player to
complete a level and move on to the next
level I'll see how we can do that right
now we have a bunch of bricks loaded
into our level and I've updated my level
here so we only have one brick that's
easy to clear and we can move on to the
next level and make sure everything
works the problem is since the bricks
are loaded into these game objects we
don't know when all the bricks have been
destroyed so let's create a new array
for the bricks and let's just load them
in here so if this top bricks is build
level will pull the bricks out of our
game objects now in our update function
we still want to loop over all of our
game objects and update them and the
same for our draw we want to go over all
of our objects and update them or draw
them so what we can do is we can have an
array here called dot dot dot this game
objects and dot dot this dot bricks so
that's going to spread the game objects
and the bricks together into one array
and then we can do the same thing here
we did before
let's make sure that works it does for
the update but let's make sure we can
draw as well so instead of this game
objects we're going to spread the game
objects as well as the bricks let's take
it up
all right so we're able to bounce off
the brick just fine however it's not
clearing the brick it's not clearing the
brick because our check here to remove
any objects that are marked for deletion
is only checking the game objects we
really just need it to check the bricks
rename this to brick see if that works
there we go we cleared our brick now
let's check to see if all the bricks are
gone so inside of our update we can say
if this stopped bricks length equals
zero new level will need to be loaded in
here let's take a look once the brick is
destroyed our console is logging so that
is working now how do we actually load
the new level well let's create a new
level real quick I'm just going to make
it a duplicate of level one
and call it these so we have our level
two instead of our game let's import
this guy and let's create an array of
our levels so this style levels is going
to be level one and level two and this
current level is going to be the index
so remember arrays start at zero so the
current level at zero will be level one
once the level reaches level current
level of one the array at index one is
level two
that'll be loaded we will say this the
current level plus plus so we'll
increment the current level and then we
will need to run the start function
again now a start function needs to know
what current level we are on so we'll
say this levels at this current level
see if that works all right so our level
did not increment now last check here is
we're checking to see if the game is at
the menu if not it returns so that is
why the new level is not being loaded so
what we can do is we can make a new game
state here let's just say a new level so
in our start we will return if it's not
equal to the menu or if the game state
is not equal to new level there we go we
also want the ball to be reset
let's make sure we have that in here we
do have a reset function that we built
last episode so I'll reset the ball set
the game objects get the bricks the last
thing we need to do is before we call
start we will say this dot game state
equals game state dot new level let's
check it out you change this too and we
have a new level and that's all it takes
to load in a second level after
completing the first I hope you've
enjoyed this game dev series I've hope
it's taught you a lot on how to build a
game and notices the very basics there's
some bugs there's a lot of things that
we can do with this game but I wanted to
keep it simple so that we could go over
the basic understanding of game
development if you enjoy the series make
sure you hit the thumbs up and subscribe
for more videos